today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet
join them at expressvpn.com
you're the ceo of one of the biggest
poverty fighting organizations in the
world
robin hood which handles like bajillions
of dollars
uh and even you're looking at it being
like this
is not enough you cannot come up with
million dollar
solutions to trillion dollar problems
yes
hallelujah i don't call what we do
charity i think charity is paternalistic
and it's offensive
right i think what we're not a charity
we're a change organization
you know we believe in changing the
fundamental structures of the society in
which we exist in
the the things that we've invested in
the most proud of are the things we no
longer invest in
yes right the thing we don't have to
invest in anymore it's either the
problem was solved
or government took it over we were the
first organization that
that invested in needle exchanges and we
did it at a time when it was really
controversial and really scary and
people saying what do you mean
you know giving giving drug dealers
clean needles
well the data was showing that if you're
looking at the rise of hiv aids
it was actually the transmission of
dirty needles that was one of the
fastest
rates for for for this transmission and
so we piloted it
and we funded it and now we don't fund
it anymore because the federal
government does it
but they were never going to be first
money in
[Music]
all right guys on today's episode of
yang speaks the conversation you are
waiting for
andrew's thoughts on kamala harris as
the vice president pick of the
democratic party but more importantly
we talk about hashtag let yank speak dnc
you're not going to want to miss this
episode then of course we wrap it up
within fascinating conversation with wes
moore
who's a ceo of robin hood and an author
and this complete
incredible human being so stay tuned
it's going to be a good one
[Music]
we're back and yank speaks for special
episode because
we've had breaking news andrew a lot has
happened since our last episode
yes kamala harris
vice president biden harris ticket
uh i'm excited no i got to know kamala
very well
on the trail it's funny like the the
different candidates
uh you're literally side by side
uh in in the case of me and kamala i
think i was at her debate neighbor
multiple times yeah one time i smuggled
a handkerchief on stage four
uh she was just like hey you carrying
things on from i was like sure
you know but but more than that
we uh we're in iowa back to back
multiple times really much more iowa
than anything else because she spent a
lot of time there
and i did too um but we have each
other's
uh contact info i got to know her
husband
too on the trail doug who's a great guy
i'm excited i think the
biden harris ticket is really hard to
beat
you know it's like it it feels balanced
uh and kamala's a freaking
powerhouse where nature yeah like she'll
she will be very very strong on the
trail
and make a lot of people very excited uh
so
it's it's great and the most important
thing always to me was
joe's uh desire for the right partner
because
he wanted someone he had the right
relationship with and it seems like he
had a relationship with kamala from way
back because she was
um friends with his son bo when he was
attorney general and she was an attorney
general
uh so yeah you know it it's a phenomenal
pick
in terms of your relationships with
candidates on the trail you were closest
i thought
with joe and kamala and maybe tulsi
forgot about corey oh my god sorry
you're right
um so i selfishly from andrew yang
perspective this is pretty cool because
you're friendly with her are friends
with her um but thoughts on the strategy
of this like in
what what do you think besides do i like
the person do i think they're a good
leader what do you think from a
political standpoint optics standpoint
what are your thoughts on
on the kamala pick well i think there's
a really great balance again
where you have uh joe who's older
than you was like a generation
younger uh you have obviously the gender
dynamic
the the race dynamic uh it it's very
balanced uh there's even a little bit of
an east coast west coast thing going
the the right i watched fox news last
night i'm always see interested in what
they say about
the vp pick and they already have tried
to brand her and ben shapiro came out
same thing said
kamala is a radical lefty and to me that
branding does not stick
i think no it really does as moderate as
they come i think it's insane to try and
call her that i think yes she's had some
california policies she's kind of been
wrapped up in or just by being a
senator from the san francisco or bay
area
um is one thing but she was an attorney
general
there is no she's a very moderate
sensible politician
so i think that won't stick i don't know
to me she's already been branded and
throwing the nonsense at her
won't stick the way it might with some
of the other lesser known vp candidates
he was considering
yeah i think they have to try that i
don't think it's correct or effective
uh but right you know at this point
they're in desperation mode
yeah it was it was fascinating like
hannity and
laura ingram were like this is the most
radical ticket the democrats have ever
run
you're like not really i think that i
don't think that's correct
i don't know i don't know how many
moderates are really watching fox news
anymore but i don't know but um
that doesn't feel right so congrats to
kamala and her team um and i'm excited i
think this is a solid pick
and we're and look the other thing the
other fact the other piece of this is
that
all of the democrats fell in line which
i think is rare like we usually have
rifts in our party
um and that was nice to see the rest of
the democratic
leadership and candidates all come out
and support her
and joe with the pick yeah i agree
congrats to kamala
and doug and the whole team your and you
know to win this thing
yeah so we're going to help which is
exciting which brings me to
other forms of helping and probably one
of the reasons many of you tuned in
because yesterday let yang
speak dnc was trending i think it got up
to number three in politics on twitter
but it was like it's top 10 in twitter
at least in the united states
so the the high level overview is that
the dnc came out with their
let's call it their speaker card um of
who's speaking all four days during the
dnc convention and we were left off that
list
which was a bit of a shock to us because
we've been in conversations with the dnc
about speaking and have been given what
seems to be some prime time slots
throughout the week we are
you know expected to speak at the
convention be a member so
and then you tweeted out um you know if
i'm honest i was expecting to speak
in the sense of to speak with the people
on that list
so your react i think the world is
interested in your your real reaction
and also why this
um why this matters to you and to
frankly our supporters
i think i commented to a journalist
that it's not like you or me were
jumping up and down
like yelling at anyone's ear being like
oh we need this spot we need that or not
uh yeah um but that there is like a real
sense that
we have a lot of people that uh
supported my campaign
many of whom were on the fence about joe
uh
and i've been telling them we need to
get behind joe and
get trump out uh and i said this makes
that case a little bit harder to make
because one reason why people
who supported me would support joe is
like okay if yang is a
big part of the team then we can advance
some of the
um ideas and policies that i ran on
it's just a harder case to make if it
seems like we are
not um being included
uh and to your points like i thought we
were being included
that was like the mystery it's like ah
like hey
like what what transpires here i want to
be clear people listening it's
it's not about us um like would you like
to speak sure but that's not the point
of this the point is we have a powerful
message and a lot of people that
supported it
and wanted this voice heard and it was
actually really touching the outpouring
of support so thank you if you were part
of it but like the outpouring of support
yesterday i was like wow
like that so that was hilarious people
that have been hated on you forever
people have hated on you forever on
msnbc or name nameless but they came out
and they were like andrew yanks beyond
there this is ridiculous
like that to me was um
i don't know funny and kind of case
important
like i was gratifying i was like oh
thank you that's so kind
really because like it did reflect on it
for a minute um because
uh you know there are other folks that
are also not on the program that ran
and um the fact that there doesn't seem
to be much of an outcry
it was really touching to me i was like
oh wow like people uh recognize what we
did
yeah so that thank you to everyone who
helped make make that
happen um yeah we're keeping making
things happening every
day twitter went nuts here we are
we'll be involved in the convention
somehow all right so today's episode
we've got
you've got wes moore man and listening
this conversation andrew
my jaw dropped like six times like what
a powerful
story and what a powerful guy you guys
hit it off
and been friends before right you knew
him prior to
running right wes and i have been
friends for years wes is like a real
life superhero where he's like an army
ranger
and author and entrepreneur and oprah's
friend
and author has a great new book
uh about five days in baltimore
and he's one of the leading anti-poverty
activists in the country where he's
the ceo of robin hood which distributes
tens hundreds of millions of dollars to
fight poverty in the new york area and
is one of like the biggest
uh anti-poverty labs um that that there
is
so thrilled to be able to sit down with
wes and we talk a little bit about how i
sat down with him when i started the
campaign because i was like hey if
anyone's going to be into
abolishing poverty it's going to be
westmore and so but i hadn't had a
chance to catch up with him
um in months so enjoy the heck out of
this conversation
author entrepreneur patriot
anti-poverty leader wes moore on yang
[Music]
speaks
euron yang speaks we think that our data
is ours
uh we should be sharing in its value we
should have control over it and
certainly we should know
if big brother is peering over our
shoulder now
in today's day and age that's easier
said than done but one way you can make
sure that your data stays safe and
secure
is by using a vpn and here at yangspeaks
we
recommend expressvpn it's number one
rated by
wired and others it's like using the
internet someplace else magically by
hitting a button
uh and you can use it to feel like
you're a secret agent
uh you can use it to access content
that's only available in europe
what the hell are they watching in
europe well you can find out so
just use expressvpn and my link is
expressvpn.com
yang you can get an extra three months
of expressvpn for free
at expressvpn.com
[Applause]
[Music]
it is my honor and pleasure to welcome
to yang speaks my good friend
the decorated veteran author
combater of poverty all-around superhero
former rhodes scholar i guess you're
always a road scholar that's the way
that [ __ ] works
west moore west welcome andrew
it's good to see you man it's good good
to be hanging out here with the yang
gang man i'm uh
i'm thankful for this i've been looking
for this for a long time man i'm proud
of you
well you and me both and we have so much
to talk about
yeah you know um i saw you when i was
just starting to
run for president when it was a little
bit more
uh crazy shall we say
and i know it's funny i tell people i
will never forget
that meeting um where where you came up
to
the office of robin hood we're talking
about poverty which almost worked and
and so then i asked you a question like
so what are you up to and you said you
know i think i'm going to run for
president
and i remember taking that pause like
wait is he
serious right now or is he saying
something's almost react and then when
you when when i realized you were
serious i remember getting up and giving
you a hug
because i was like this is so i mean
it's so unbelievably bold and brave and
beautiful
and and when you think about it in in
respect of
where we are as a nation and what we
need
you know we've got to be thinking bold
we got to be thinking brave on this
stuff because it's uh
i think that's kind of what the moment
uh you know it's what the moment
you know requires and ask for so i will
i will never forget
uh exactly where we were in my office
and where we're sitting when you first
told me
that you were running for president yeah
and that was one of the
best reactions i got thank you guys i
remember it too
um and and your perspective on so much
of this and we're going to talk about
your new book
uh five days because it's very timely
and of the moment
but i feel like your perspective is
exactly
what we need where you grew up uh you
know rough
uh background saw your father pass i
believe at a young age
shifted around moved around had trouble
in school
uh were sent to military school for a
while which was
a code i i thought for like you know
this kid can't stop getting into trouble
[Laughter]
um and then you went to a junior college
uh and then uh transferred to hopkins
wound up a rhodes scholar and then this
is what the turn i love so much is that
you wound up working
in finance but then you
self-ejected out of there and became an
army ranger a paratrooper
where you then uh became a decorated
combat veteran
um instead of doing what frankly like 99
of people in that circumstance do which
is just try and stay near the money tree
and and have have some of like the
um you know the fruit of the money tree
drop on your your head and then convince
yourself that it was all because of how
awesome you were
um so then you you went uh
after coming back from from the military
um wrote
multiple best-selling books including
the other west moore that i think they
use in schools around the country
i became a host on oprah and then
when you and i were in your office
you're the ceo of one of the biggest
poverty fighting organizations in the
world robin hood which handles
like bajillions of dollars like how much
you guys give away in like a given year
yeah i mean a given year we'll do
anywhere from
you know 150 to 200 in in its existence
robin hood is giving away
uh north of three billion dollars to the
poverty fight yeah when you hear 150
like you might be thinking thousand he's
talking about millions
this organization uh gives away
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
regular two organizations in new york
city that's like the domain
and so when you and i were talking
so to me your perspective is similar to
mine in that you sort of
headed all the way up into the belly of
the beast or like the heights
of high finance and now massive
philanthropy one of the most impactful
philanthropies in the world
uh and even you're looking at it being
like this
is not enough like we need to go much
much
bigger if we're going to address these
problems
in communities not just in new york but
around the country
yeah and but but frankly and you know
and i'm
um i am very i'm very humbled by the
work that we're doing i'm
really excited about the work that we're
involved in right now and how robinhood
has just continued to
to push the needle on a lot of really
important issues
and not just with our funding with our
voice with our advocacy with our
partnerships and all these other
respects
but but we also have to move with a
sense of humility
in the idea that you cannot come up with
million-dollar solutions to trillion
dollar problems
yes hallelujah so i mean like we have to
be
we have to be clear about the enemy
that we have here and and how big and
how broad and how entrenched
oftentimes it is and so you know we we
cannot you know
and one thing i always you know talk
about with robin hood
is you know i when people say you know
how big is the charity you know
i say i don't i don't call what we do
charity i think charity is paternalistic
and it's offensive
right i think what we're not a charity
we're a change organization
you know we believe in changing the
fundamental structures of the society in
which we exist in
and there is no patchwork solutions to
being able to address the fact
that we have long-term structural breaks
in the way we think about everything
from housing to the way we think about
transportation
to the way we think about education to
the way we think about justice reform to
the way we think about health mental and
physical health
i mean all of these aspects play into
this idea that we have to just reframe
and rethink things
when it comes to the policy mechanisms
that we're going to support and endorse
and also about how we're thinking about
the free usage of capital
within our society who needs it who gets
it when do they get it
and how can we think use that as a way
of creating true measures and levers
of sustainable economic mobility for
families
yeah i know robin hood is all about
measurements you know when we were
in touch at the very beginning of the
pandemic we were talking about just
trying to get economic relief out to
people
and sometimes people ask me like hey how
did you measure
what the thousand recipients in the
bronx did with a thousand dollars each
um that they received and i was frank
and i was like i'm like
i'm totally confident that the money
went to the good things like we did not
follow the people around we don't have
uh
you know phds studying what they did
with a thousand dollars we were just
very very confident that if you were a
struggling family in the bronx the
beginning of the pandemic
um on food stamps or otherwise like if
we give you a thousand dollars it's
gonna go to something
uh positive i'm telling andrew it's and
it's it's one of these things because we
are
uh we are a very data-driven
organization i'm a very data-driven
leader like i believe
in data deeply i also know this
is that uh you know the while we can
literally put a quantifiable
roi on each dollar that's investing to
organizations because we
literally structure that the way we
think about our investments you know
when to hear people make this argument
of well but if we give
you know the money to individuals what
are they going to spend it on
like we have to learn that you can be
you you can be generous and not
judgmental yeah
that we are talking about families who
are in some of the deepest most dire
situations if you take a look at new
york alone
in the past and this is research that we
do we have a partnership with columbia
university to create something called
the poverty tracker
which is really a longitudinal data set
for 4
000 families that we follow and you can
get kind of real-time
uh trend trend analysis right um
here's what we found that half of new
yorkers
have been have have have suffered the
impacts of poverty for at least a year
over the past four years this was pre
covered 19.
not half of a borough not half of a
demographic group
half of the city has been in poverty for
at least a year
over the past four years so we're not
talking about a new phenomenon that
we're dealing with they're talking about
that
that that half of the city is enduring
the pain of poverty on a daily basis
and and you know of the many things that
i'm i'm truly truly proud of
that how this organization has been able
to move and mobilize in this moment
uh i think about the work that we were
able to do with the with the relief fund
and it goes back directly to
not just what you were talking about but
in many ways the thesis that you've been
arguing for years
right is that you know if so at the
onset of coven 19 at the answer to the
pandemic you know we
reactivated the robinhood relief fund
which was to support the highest need
new yorkers who were impacted by kobe 19
and really prioritize the new yorkers
that have been
left out of federal aid responses such
as
low-income children and families
immigrant communities college students
low-wage workers because people forget
even when you look at the cares act and
people say well wasn't there a cash
assistance element to the cares act
yes but millions of people were left out
of it people missed so many people
i mean and in a very in a very in a very
intentional way
andrew it's like so people were
undocumented
despite them even being workers and
taxpayers they didn't benefit from
cash assistance if you were part of a
mixed status family
you didn't benefit from cash assistance
if you were working but not making
enough
to maintain pains of the taxes you
didn't benefit at all that pains me the
most
that's exactly right at like the income
uh tax filing threshold uh the other one
that pains me as
students if you're a young student
exactly you didn't benefit
you didn't you didn't benefit from this
and so we had a federal policy that was
put into place
but that intentionally left out in many
communities who were oftentimes
you know the most vulnerable and and we
were prioritizing those
who were most impacted by the vast
racial and health disparities that have
been exacerbated by covet 19. 75 percent
of new york's low-wage of new york's
low-wage workers
you know called to stay on the front
lines of the pandemic were people
of color are our essential workers and
so
when we thought about how can we quickly
mobilize cash and assistance uh
you know and we think about the fact
that even since the pandemic began since
the
onset we've now allocated over 37
million dollars
and just in that time period alone or
made over 500 grants
to over 430 organizations so i mean so
we've been moving fast to get
cash in and cash out the door but one of
the things that we were able to do
working with the community and through
the community to identify what some of
the greatest needs were
some of the greatest needs were basic
cash assistance
yes basic cash assistance where you know
46
46 you know percent of our grants that
we made in that through our relief fund
were to provide emergency cash
assistance for
low-income new yorkers to cover
necessities and
and we weren't asking them to fill out
theses to explain
what were your necessities what are you
going to do with it we need to see
receipts
no what we're saying is here's support
god speed and we want to make sure that
this does not have to become something
that just becomes a repetitive process
that these families and these in these
communities are then forced to endure
and so how to rethink this whole process
how we're thinking
you know philanthropy's role in this
became a really important and speedy
exercise
that not just us but also you know we
watched a lot of other organizations
take real leadership in it and it was it
was it was really great to see
[Music]
i'd say the number one concern that
most of us have during this pandemic is
just trying to stay positive and healthy
throughout you know a lot of the days
blend in with each other
and one way you can take better care of
yourself and make sure you're eating
right is to join freshly
they send you food that's pre-prepared
it's
delicious it's easy if you don't know
how to cook
it's perfect just order freshly
and they send you the food you eat it
and you feel better about yourself
because it wasn't crap
that's really like you could maybe
freshly should rebrand itself
not crap because because i have to say
um for whatever reason it's so easy to
eat crap right now i don't know about
the rest of you it's like you go down
you go to that kitchen and whatever is
there is just like oh sure like you just
want to
freaking shovel it into your mouth so
instead you can shovel fresh cooked
healthy food into your mouth with
freshly
it makes you feel a lot better you wake
up the next day feeling
great and freshly.com is offering our
listeners forty dollars off for their
first two orders
at freshly.com yang that's freshly.com
look invest in yourself invest in your
health
this is a no-brainer for folks who
aren't exactly tearing it up in the
kitchen
or on the treadmill uh right now which i
suspect is
most all of us so andrew my apartment
building has not had gas for like
a year and i'm in a war with the
management company
because you can't cook and so freshly
has been a godsend because i don't have
any other options
that's remotely healthy so if you're my
management company and you're listening
to this
screw you and for those of you who are
not the vast majority who are not
related to my management company check
out freshly because
um not being physically able to cook has
led me to freshly.com so freshview.com
check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
well you're in a similar boat to the
boat i've been in
which is you're doing tremendous work
that you believe in and it's very
i mean in your case it's extraordinary
like you know top of the line
um and then you also see like hey i'm
not actually
solving the problem that even if i have
37 million i give to these orgs it's
like you know
i should probably have another couple
zeros and even then you know
and and for anyone listening to this
they're like holy cow like you know
this org has a size and scale and heft
that most orgs can only dream of
uh it's it's one reason why i think your
book is
is so timely and you obviously were
working on it before
everything that happened with george
floyd and nationwide
but it's about it's called five days and
it's about
the five days at the center of the
um freddie gray protests
uh in baltimore that racked the city we
all remember the images we all remember
um the uh the cvs and like that the
other
um uh indelible
uh images we have from um the freddie
gray protests
um so tell me about obviously you're in
baltimore right now you're from
baltimore
uh and so you the city's near and dear
to your heart
um how did you experience um those
protests in real time
um and then how did this book come about
yeah you know it's
um it's wow because i think about the
this book was actually set to be
released i believe was on april 14th
it was especially released on the
anniversary of uh of
of everything that happened in the in
the uprising in baltimore around around
freddie gray's death
and it was probably around the beginning
of march when i called my publisher
and said we can't release it then and i
told him because you know like we're
that's when we're right in the heat of
everything going on with covet
i i was like you know i'm trying to i'm
trying to run a very big organization
right now the whole world is shifting
under our feet and i've got to stay
focused
and so they're like no no we get it and
um and they said all right what about
and they just picked a random date
they're like what about um
you know june 23rd and i said that
sounds good i mean
at that point i was like as long as it's
not now yeah i'm good right i got to
stay focused on this
and it just so happened that june 20 you
know a couple weeks after we made the
final decision to push the date back
is when we first learned the names ahmad
arbury
and brianna taylor and george floyd
and there's actually a horror
to the timeliness of it in the way that
a date
that they picked that was relatively
arbitrary
is so timely and there's a heart of that
when we think about when would there
have not been a timely moment to have
this conversation
about inequity in our society
and racial inequity and you know i
remember it the whole thing kind of
begun
began when i was sitting in in freddie
gray's funeral and
and for those who who might not remember
you know freddie gray was a
a 25 year old young man uh in baltimore
who made eye contact with police and ran
um the reason i say that is because that
was his crime
was if you are in a high crime
oftentimes high poverty area
making eye contact with police and
running
is enough to trigger probable cause had
he done that in a wealthy neighborhood
he had been going for a jog but he makes
eye contact with police and runs
in harlem park sandtown winchester which
are two areas of baltimore west
baltimore deep poverty
and uh he's arrested an hour after he's
arrested
he's in a coma and when he when he's
finally taken to the university of
maryland medical center it is deemed
that he has three broken vertebrae and a
crushed voice box
and a crushed larynx and so there were
protests that took place in baltimore
for two weeks after demanding justice
and accountability saying you know how
is someone arrested
and an hour later they're in a coma and
no one has an answer
for what happened and uh and the morning
of his funeral i went to the funeral and
andrew was crazy because i remember
sitting in the back of the church
and i didn't feel like i had earned the
right to make that walk
up to go view the body so i just sat in
the back
and i left the funeral and i had to fly
to boston to give a talk on poverty
and the irony of that hit me really hard
that the night of his funeral was the
night that baltimore
started this process and that's when you
saw the unrest take place literally to
the point that by
six o'clock that night the governor had
called in the national guard
and would then put baltimore under a
state of emergency in a curfew
and um and i found myself in boston
talking about poverty both because the
work that i was doing because at that
point i was running an organization
um that i that i founded that focused on
helping students john first generally
first generation students
make it and stay in college but i also
knew they were there to kind of talk
about my past
and my background and put me up as an
example
[Music]
and it was in that moment
that i started realizing how dangerous
that was
how it made me complicit as well wow
that that we can sit there and say
and look at the people who make it and
say it's because of them and
that's such a great story and then look
at ones who don't
and say it's because of them and it's
because they didn't work hard without
understanding the systems that we still
have in place
well that that's what your book the
other westmore is all about that's
exactly right
right it's about the same neighborhood
and one winds up here and then the other
ones up
you know in jail that's right and how
and how we are so
quick as a society to either
congratulate or to castigate
without being willing to understand or
indict systems
that we have in all of this and i think
about this in context and
you know earlier on this week uh you
know we had uh
the the the current governor of maryland
you know he announced that he's that
he's putting he's putting out a book
right and in the book he starts talking
a lot about
uh this moment and he was the brand new
governor i think he was governor for for
uh for
for three months at the time when
everything jumped off with freddie gray
but during this book
he spends time and and the exact quote
that he used
when he was describing the when
describing freddie gray was
he called him a crips gang connected
street level drug dealer with a long
criminal rap sheet
i spent four years focusing on and
understanding what happened around
freddie gray and what happened in
baltimore around those times
and and here's what i do know and i can
say this definitively that the story of
freddie gray's life
is a story of societal failure because
this was a young man who was born
underweight and premature he was also
born addicted to heroin because his
mother battled heroin addiction for much
of her life
she grew up in deep poverty her entire
life
she gives birth to twins once the twins
are old enough that they actually gain
enough weight that they're able to leave
the hospital
they move into a housing project on
north cary street over in over in west
baltimore
and that housing project in 2009 along
with 480 other homes
were actually cited in a civil lawsuit
because of the endemic levels of lead
inside of that house so
you know and you know andrew it's like
you know the cdc right
the center for disease control indicates
that if a person has six milliliters
of lead in every deciliter of blood but
in every deciliter of blood
that person will have cognitive damages
for the remainder of their life
right we've known this is a neurotoxin
for a century
if a person of six freddie gray
had 36. so this was a young man who was
born premature
underweight addicted to heroin
and lead poisoned and by that time in
his life
he's too and so when we're making these
judgments
about people by the time he was in fifth
grade he was four grade levels behind in
reading because of the cognitive damage
of of the lead poisoning
you know he finished his last recorded
day of school in
the baltimore city school system was in
tenth grade
and he was 19 years old he had been in
special education classes his entire
academic career because of the lead
poisoning and so when we're i'm
i'm hearing this uh where we're you know
hearing the current governor making
points about how
well you know he was a he was no he was
no choir boy he was no singer in the
church choir
i know he wasn't but i also know this is
that freddie gray never had a shot
freddie gray never had a chance and that
was the point
of all this is that we have to
understand all of these moments and all
these periods
we have got to understand it with a
sense of context because the truth is
is that every system that touched
freddie's life whether it was the health
system
or the housing system or the george
education system
or our policing system that it not only
failed to help him
but it did severe and lasting damage
and now we see the product of that yeah
and
he dies in police uh custody after an
hour i mean
like that that's like the brutal
end you know to a story of institutional
uh failure and and
the tough part of it is that like if you
have
a set of systems or an economy that's
grinding people up
and then someone uh
dies as a result it's almost like a
reflex to say well what was wrong with
this person
uh you know like because that that's
actually a more comforting
stance and narrative than to say like
wait a minute like maybe we've had
uh problems up and down for years and
decades and generations
uh or even the fact that in his case i
mean you know he's born to a mother's
addicted to heroin i mean you could
probably trace some
some uh um problems even before he's
born
um to to various failures and this is
something so
the book one of the things in the book
that struck me was um there's a woman uh
i believe her name is tawanda jones yeah
and she's
she's protesting like uh i believe is
her brother or
like someone else who uh
who was a victim of police violence and
uh so she's holding like weekly
protests before freddie uh
dies and and then the freddie gray
protests end up getting built into like
a pre-existing and this struck me
forcibly because you're like wow there's
like a constant sort of waterfall
of impacted families and protests
that pre-exist any one person where
everyone's looking around being like who
are you protesting because
because they had like like different
family members who'd been
uh victimized so that was one thing
where i was like wow like
if you're in that environment like that
that that is uh
mind-blowing for for most i'm telling
andrew
one of the most fascinating things for
me about the project of writing five
days
was first identifying who were the
people that i wanted to follow
over this five-day period that i wanted
to i wanted the reader
to be able to walk through this era
walk through this chaos through their
eyes through the eyes of these people
and
one of the first people i knew that i
was like i've got to make sure she's
profiled
is tawanda jones and because
it's important to remember that even in
the two years before freddie gray
right there was chris brown
there was anthony anderson and there was
her brother
tyrone west and every
wednesday still to this day in fact she
just had the 371st
straight west wednesday where every
wednesday she protests
sometimes it's just her and maybe one
other person and sometimes she's got
hundreds of people with her
but rain sleet snow doesn't matter she
protests and she protests the fact that
even prior to all this where she was and
she found ourselves and that's having
this amazing conversation with her where
she would say
you know i was so proud to march with
the grey family when they called me and
asked me
and i was so proud of the fact that the
city was standing up
and saying you know yes we want justice
and yes we have to address policing
but she said but i just also felt a
certain type of way
where i still thought to myself but
where was this when my brother was
killed
right where was this when my brother's
body was literally left in the middle of
the street with mace all over him
and boot prints all over his body where
was this
and so she every wednesday she protests
demanding justice and accountability for
what happened to her brother
and and she was she was such a
fascinating
person to follow over that five day
period especially when you look at it in
context of who some of the other people
were right so
you had tawanda but then i also you know
you know spend time following
major mark partee who's a baltimore city
police major
who grew up in west baltimore and i
remember him specifically telling me
before where he said listen
you know i know that none of my
colleagues woke up that morning with
homicide in their mind
but i also know that for kids in west
baltimore where i grew up
i know why they don't believe me right
or or following someone like greg butler
who's a basketball star turned protester
or following someone like john angelos
who's the son of the owner of the
baltimore orioles
literally you know a billionaire who was
also the head of baseball operations for
the orioles
and base and and on the wednesday after
baseball played its first ever game with
no fans now we're doing all the time
but their first ever game with no fans
when the orioles played the chicago
white sox
and it was because john angelos was one
of the people in the room making the
final decision
of basically saying no we should play
the game even though the city is in the
state of emergency
because the world needs to see this and
so watching the various
and different perspectives of people
like that people liking nick mosby
who's a city councilman at the time
whose wife was the state's attorney
in baltimore but watching it through
their eyes
i think uh you know hopefully provided a
real
kaleidoscope understanding of the
complexity of the moment
but also that if we thought that this
was just about
policing or just about freddie
that we were missing a bigger point that
society was trying to tell us something
else
that they were hoping that we would
actually pay attention to well
there was another fact in the tawanda
jones
narrative that also hit me uh really
hard which was that
um and i'm not sure if it was for her
brother or for another
victim but that they essentially
settled for a million dollars and gave
it to the
three survivors of the victim of police
brutality
um and and that struck me because it was
a situation where it's like well
you clearly know that something went
terribly wrong if
you were settling with a family but but
there's no
um like no arrests made no
accountability it's just like there's a
death and then there's like some
uh some money and one of the things that
i found when i was researching the
extent of the problem
of police misconduct was that that
actually happens all over the country
where they're they're settling these
civil judgments to the tune of over a
billion dollars a year
in the aggregate um and so that's their
way of papering over this problem
um and so if you think about like the
the number of times it happens
and no one gets a dime or the number of
times it happens and someone sues and
it's completely unsuccessful because the
can you imagine trying to sue your local
police department i mean that sounds
uh like very very difficult to me you
know like like you feel like everything
would be uphill
so the fact that you're still getting a
billion dollars under those conditions
struck me as a sign that the problem is
orders of magnitude bigger like if you
had to try and throw
a measurement on it you were like police
are causing billions of dollars
of bodily harm to americans
every single year and the fact that that
was happening in baltimore where there's
like no real responsibility but here's
some
like blood money essentially it's like
hey we killed your dad but you know
here's a little bit of money like maybe
that makes up for it like that also
hit me really hard it was and honestly
and i think tawanda's story is such a
powerful one around it because
she didn't take any money and it was for
that reason
because they also knew that with taking
the payment meant there was also uh you
know there was also a sense there's also
an agreement to never talk about this
right and she's like i'm not going to
stop talking about it so she never took
any money
for a while but and i and and you bring
up an
incredibly important point because there
is this narrative
about baltimore when people say so what
what brought the temperature down what
calmed everything down in baltimore
and and oftentimes the narrative is well
it was when the national guard
were called in right that's not true
because you know first of all i can i
can tell you as a person who
you know very proudly wore the uniform
you know often times when
you introduce military personnel into
situations that doesn't calm situations
down
right but the second thing and the most
important thing to remember is
that some of the biggest protests that
were going to take place
in baltimore were actually set to take
place the saturday after
the unrest what happened why those
protests never happened wasn't because
the national guard was there the
national guard was already there when
they were being planned
what happened was was when the state's
attorney marilyn mosby
announced she was pressing charges
against the six officers
because up until that point you're
absolutely right andrew it's like the
the thread was common right something
happened
a payout ensued and it went away
that was a general trend right but
this was the first time in baltimore
history
where the state's attorney was actually
saying no
i'm actually pressing charges against
these officers for misconduct
i remember being there andrew where
there was almost this celebratory vibe
throughout the streets of baltimore
because people were shocked people like
wait
wait she announced what that they're
arresting the officers
for that because we hadn't we had never
seen that
before and now granted fast forward you
know we had two of the officers were
found not guilty
for the officers were their case their
charges were were dismissed um
but that moment that was what actually
brought the temperature down
because people thought for the first
time we actually might see
justice and what's interesting now i
think even when you look at what
happened with what's happened with
george floyd
one of the big differences i think
between then and now is the bar has been
risen
where at that point the charges
were like whoa that's a big deal calmed
everything down
now charges have been filed the bar
isn't about charges anymore
the bar is convictions and that's going
to be the real test to see can you
actually get convictions
for you know for for these for these
instances in the case of george floyd
when you are literally watching a grown
man in handcuffs
on the ground with another man
nonchalantly leaning his knee into his
neck until he can no longer breathe
i mean the bar is not can we get an
arrest the bar is
conviction for that
yeah you can see why the standards are
high on both sides or at least you know
like
and you you've dug into this the same
way i have where if you're a local
attorney or state's attorney or an
attorney general the last thing you
generally want to do is pick a fight
with your law enforcement
department because you literally work
with them hand in hand all the time
absolutely
and even if it's like the state level
you still know the same people the
universe is very very small
um so so there's like a very every
incentive for that person not to
bring charges is number one and then
number two the legal standard around
convicting
a police officer is almost ridiculously
high
like in a lot of places the police
officer is like well you know i felt
threatened or the person's like making
and that's enough
and then that that's enough it's like
it's literally so you have to get inside
their brain and be
like well turn and like it's very hard
to prove that and not
you know and so if you're a jury you
look up and say what's the standard i'm
working with and then you say well i
guess this person's
um not guilty so the conviction standard
is going to be very very different than
the
uh bring the suit standard and bring the
suit standard itself was very very high
um and and it was high enough where in
in baltimore's case everyone was so
shocked that they
um like you know felt like their mission
had been at least somewhat achieved
it sounds like that's right and
particularly because there was there was
no precedent
to that before so the fact that bar uh
the fact that that that that glass
ceiling had been shattered it was pretty
remarkable that it happened
and but and but but this actually really
is an important point too when
when people are saying well we have to
make sure we are supporting
our law enforcement et cetera um i agree
and and trust me you know as as someone
who
you know who has had the experience of
knowing what it's like to to to put on a
uniform and walk into
areas and communities that you're not
familiar with i understand how
complicated the job is we do need to
support them
and at the same time what we also have
to do is come up with policies and rules
and structures
that can support the ones who are doing
the good work and be able to
make sure we don't have to have these
these incidents continue to happen
within our societies
you know i i i think about it in context
of even
you know the the debate that's taking
place right now about
defund the police or abolish the police
etc and i make it very clear i am not
for abolishing the police
i am for abolishing police brutality i'm
for abolishing race-based policing
i'm i am for abolishing the the
hyper-militarization of policing
that we have within our society right
now i'm absolutely for abolishing that
you know but i also know that how we are
thinking about the safety and security
for our communities
uh that can happen just with some blind
or blanket statement of of
support law enforcement we have to be
clear about what that means
yes and one of the most effective ways
you can actually support them
is by making sure that we are asking we
are tasking them to do the tasks
that they should be doing and also that
we are holding those accountable who
should be held accountable
it's impossible for me to have a good
apple bad apple conversation
when this isn't about good apples bad
apples it's about systems
and we have to really rethink systems in
all this if we're going to plan on being
effective
well one of the things i can say looking
at it is that
all of the incentives in the system um
steer a particular direction you know
what i mean and it's one reason why
people
grow so frustrated and angry
because they see that the system's
working for certain people generally
those who are within the system or
custodians of the system
and not members of the public that in
theory the system supposed to be
looking out for or serving um you know
i'm not sure if this was the intention
but i felt like with a book
being written with these different
perspectives and characters it almost
felt like it could be a docu-series or a
movie i'm not sure
i mean you obviously have a lot of
experience with with that medium as well
um so i i don't know if that was
part of the um the thinking you know
it's funny
it was not part of the thinking i've
been i've been really humbled by
by the response to the book um you know
people are people are getting it and
they're picking it up and and that's
been really exciting also
you know we have now seen where people
are are saying you know there's
is there another way to tell the story
too by using other you know other
medians
to be able to tell the story as well
television film etcetera and i
um you know but the thing i think that
is i really liked about it was
it shows how quickly these things can
turn
and it shows how quickly the arc of not
just a societal arc
but the individual arc can move uh in
these moments
if you talk to most people on saturday
and you said to them i just want to let
you know that in five days
the city is going to be under a state of
emergency they're going to be national
guardsmen
in military uniforms patrolling our
streets we will have had tens of
millions of dollars of damage
already that we would have seen um we
would have played baseball games with no
one inside the stadium
and we would have played baseball games
with people being with fans being forced
to stay in
the stadium all these things would have
happened and you would have why and then
and then not to mention the individual
level and
you know i don't want to spoil it but
you know for people to pick it up when
you watch where for example
major party started at the beginning of
the book and where he ended
in terms of his career prospects when
you look at the life prospects of where
greg butler started and where he ended
if you look at just the arc of these
individuals during this time period
it's a staggering shift and that's the
point is uh and you know where what i
think i hope people
understand is we watched a major
american city implode in five days
this doesn't take long and and the thing
about it is is that
we are we are pre-baking an incredibly
powerful explosive
and we're giving it a very short wick
and when these incidents happen
all they are is they are sparks and they
are sparks and when that wick gets
caught
it's a very short period of time before
it wears down and then we have the
explosive
and that's i think in many ways what we
saw in baltimore five years ago
[Music]
if you're a parent right now you are
concerned about
a lot of things where your kids learning
education health environment and one
thing you can do
that will make an immediate difference
is join litterati
it's the leading kids book club in
america it
sends you and your child five new and
unique kids books
every month you don't have to do
anything you set and forget it and then
these books arrive
and then you open it your child uh
is pumped about bedtime and story time
this was made for parents like you if
you're busy you're tied up
and you want a subscription book club
that makes it easy just to find
unique and interesting books for your
kids straight to your doorstep
i'm a big fan who would not be a big fan
of freaking kids creative books getting
sent to your home
if you are a parent and you love your
child uh you should
join literary uh if you don't i don't
know what it says about you as a parent
you have to
if you love your child um if you don't
have a child
uh join too then send it to someone with
a child
yeah that that's yeah that's probably
overboard but for a limited time
i don't have kids yeah that's not for me
but my friends you're like
i swear by literary fully endorsed it
does make a great gift
if you have friends with kids you don't
have don't have kids so for a limited
time go to literary.com
yang for 25 off your first two orders
that's the best offer available anywhere
to get it you have to go to literary.com
yang for 25
off your first two orders how do you
spell literati if you don't know you're
not literati
but it's uh it's spelled like it sounds
literary.com
[Applause]
how concerned are you about
our societal integrity right now
because i'm very concerned you know like
like the trends that you
have been fighting for years were in
place before kovid
now kovit has decimated
opportunities in many communities they
don't have a cushion
they can fall back on to the extent that
they were eligible for leaf money it
ran out weeks ago and i'm the numbers
guy 42
of these jobs are not returning and we
have to start facing facts there's like
this
completely nonsensical like oh maybe
we'll just snap back to normal
and then i ask people it's like are you
going to be running out to the
bar concert hall sporting event like any
time like that's right
you like making a dash for uh you know
the bus
yeah you know it's like like uh so it's
like you
times you know 100 million like no one's
gonna be doing this google has a hiring
freeze like where the heck is someone
and they're still printing money so if
you like take the average small business
it's not like they're going to be
looking to hire folks who just got laid
off from the
um the bar the nail salon like the what
have you
um so i'm terrified as to
what that can become very quickly
like i i think that there's going to be
disintegration like on a personal level
disintegration like a family level
disintegration
on these on the low these communities
and
that can result in
violence like combustion
your description of certain communities
as being built up of flammable material
with very short wicks
i agree uh and how so how concerned are
you
about the fact that we may be witnessing
some terrible scenes in the united
states
um over the next coming weeks and months
you know i'm uh i'm i'm very concerned
um to be very honest i uh and i'm very
concerned because i feel like
much of the frustration it isn't new
and it's justified right i mean you you
you bring up
you bring up some really important
points andrew it's
you know prior to covet 19 we weren't
good
right that we were sick already so these
we weren't just walking around like
things
everything's everything's gravy and and
then kobet hit and things got crazy
you know if you look at the people who
lost their jobs
since covet 19. 23 percent of people who
lost their jobs
uh due to covert 19 were living in
poverty before colby 19.
right this was the working poor people
who were working jobs
in many cases multiple jobs and still
were living below the poverty line
that was pre-coveted 19 that we had that
reality
pre-code 19 we had the reality where 40
percent of people could not afford a 400
dollar shock with cash
right pre-koban 19 now we've seen that
shock and it is real
and it is much more than 400 and so i am
i'm i'm genuinely concerned
and i'm but i'm specifically genuinely
concerned if we don't
act yes and and what i mean by act is
not just like
you know while while and i say this with
with a tremendous amount of appreciation
and humility i have watched how people
have been so generous
during this moment and being able to
give to organizations and give to
foundations and get to social service
networks
and do all that kind of stuff in the
most beautiful of ways and i'm so
thankful for that and i always will be i
also
know this is that we have the type of
headwinds
that there is not going to be enough
philanthropy that's going to be able to
address it yes
i think about in the country right now
there is a round
around 700 billion dollars every year
that goes towards philanthropy
and people say like wow that's a really
big number i didn't realize number so
big that is true now
here's the reality half of that goes to
colleges and universities
alma maters right so it's not 700
billion
now we're now we are we are looking at
350 billion okay
now people can say well that's still a
pretty big number fair that is a big
number
half of that goes to homes of worship
and hospitals
so now we're down to 175 billion for
everything else for housing
for children for education for seniors
for the environment
for veterans for poverty
these problems are much bigger than that
and so federal
policies and state and local protections
including things like
expanded unemployment and benefits
stimulus payments
snap benefits increases eviction
moratoriums
you know these are all things that have
helped people survive
the past four months survive the past
four months
and we have now the prospect of tens of
millions of people
that will fall deeper into poverty
without continued aid supports and
expansions
you know that include the immigration
that include immigrant communities that
who often times
have been left out of the first tranche
of all this and so
i am i'm i'm especially and particularly
nervous
about this next phase and where we are
particularly if we cannot get serious
about coming up with ways to be able to
support in
in a really fully functional way that's
able to address the problem that we
actually have in hand
i want to uh like smash my head against
a wall
pull my hair out like you know gnash my
teeth over the fact that
our government is not seeing the obvious
uh you know like the
the fact that we need to go much bigger
in terms of
uh emergency cash relief for people i
would expand it beyond the irs mechanism
i
did not hate the fact that they used the
ios as a way to get cash out to people
um but it but it missed a lot of folks
you know and and my organization
we just were like what's your venmo
what's your cash app what's your paypal
let's just get you money in a way that
you actually can get it quick
um there's no reason our government
cannot do the same thing if it was like
we should just be shoveling resources
out to people
as quickly as possible and there are
some boneheads
uh in congress who are just looking at
it the exact wrong way where they're
like oh
people aren't working or oh the deficit
it's like are you kidding me like both
of those are
so like you know inflation i mean we're
in them
probably in the process of entering a
deflationary cycle because no one wants
to
spend or take risks uh so we should be
putting money into people's hands uh as
quickly as possible and effectively
and if we don't do it i think we're
going to witness
the disintegration of many many
uh families communities lives
and it's going to be uh it's going to be
devastating catastrophic and you know
and this
this actually gives us an interesting
opportunity andrew to actually rethink a
lot of
things and a lot of systems that should
have been rethought prior
to covert 19 right so we absolutely need
to do things like you know continue the
federal unemployment insurance benefits
we absolutely need to do things like you
know increase maximum snap benefits and
extend
the pandemic ebt programs um uh you know
improving child tax credits by making
them fully refundable those type of
things
we know those things have to be in place
but there's also some other bigger
things
that we think about as well consider the
fact that over the past four months
we've now watched 5.6 million people
lose their health insurance
and oftentimes that's because we had a
health insurance system that is based on
employer insurance so when we lose 11
years of job growth in 11 weeks
it didn't make sense before but we're
watching the impacts and the
implications
of now watching over 5 million people
who are now
uninsured because their jobs went away
and how do we decouple
these things how are we having
conversation around education i am
terribly concerned
about what's going to happen in the fall
yes i just had conversations with uh
with
um emily oster i don't know if you you
know yeah
yeah uh about uh how school districts
are preparing or not preparing really
that's right and and the the thought is
that uh many schools are going to feel
like
discretion is the better part of valor
and as as soon as
someone gets sick or even beforehand
they were like well like let's send
everyone home
which has its own set of devastating
effects on various families like it
seems like quote unquote like the
responsible thing to do but it actually
is abdicating responsibility for
a lot of kids and families and not to
mention the fact that you know in
addition to the fact that we're watching
this
this seismic educational gap that is
about to blow open if we're not being
incredibly deliberate about it but
you know we forget that our schools are
the largest food provider for children
in the country
our schools are the largest mental
health provider for children in the
country
our schools are the largest child care
provider for families in this country
so it's not just what they are the kids
learning
you know reading writing and that's just
all the other things
yes that schools provide to families and
so this give but this gives us an
interesting opportunity to actually take
some things that we just
we swallowed as truth we swallowed as
fact
and allows us to say is there a way to
actually reevaluate
right is there a way to actually think
differently and say
should we be having conversations about
school years
and school days should we be having
conversations about the ways we are
compensating our teachers
and when you consider the the heroic
work that they are doing
should we be having conversations about
completely rethinking the educational
structure
uh the you know how many how many days
and years
and and weeks we have students who are
inside a formalized classroom
how do we have a conversation on making
all these assets like tablets and
computers completely universal rights
for kids
man i mean i i agree with you
that we need to reinvent and rethink
many of these things given the nature of
the crisis we're in
uh i just throw my hands up as to
whether that
investment and reimagining is happening
you know like we just seem
stuck and then when we're not able to
deliver on what we used to do then we're
like well i guess we're not going to do
a whole heck of a lot of anything
you know particularly for people who uh
are
toward the bottom of the resource level
i mean uh what emily was saying to me
was that some
rich families are just getting some like
old school medieval style tutor who
comes and like lives with a kid and like
it goes back to like the
you know some kind of uh strange
game of thrones type arrangement where
you have like you know i mean like
that's what's going on with like
families at the top
i i mean i i hope that we do reinvent
these systems uh we need to rewrite the
rules of the economy in my mind and
you're 100
right that philanthropy doesn't have the
right scale you know you're looking at
it i mean we're
like a 22 trillion dollar economy
pre-crisis
you kneecap us like you knock one leg
out
i mean like you you need trillions of
dollars to try and
shore up where that leg used to be uh
and the scale of philanthropy even if
we're all to get channeled towards it
and i'm like you it's like i appreciate
everyone who's actually stepping up i
mean it's great
um but you know given the size of the
whole
you need our government to get it [ __ ]
together and our government does not
seem to have it [ __ ] together
yeah but i do think though that that's
actually a unique place also where
philanthropy can play
um because shaping government that's
right
well no because i think philanthropy
philanthropy needs to appreciate the
fact that we're not just check writers
right that i i believe deeply that the
most powerful tool that i have in my
disposal is not the purse
it's our voice it's the fact that when
you think about
these philanthropic organizations and
these social service organizations
that it's not just the fact that we can
influence and we can use our we can we
can create
catalytic capital right we can we can be
venture philanthropist we can invest
early we can de-risk things and there is
an important
component to that within our large
society trial with me brother let's put
some ubi
let's de-risk that and then the
government will come in and be like hey
look at that
that but that [ __ ] but that that that's
that is the unique role of philanthropy
and i agree
and so so you i mean so i think about
that i think about the role of how we've
even thought about it
within within our relief fund right
we're part of the reason that i'm so
excited that we were able to generate
and and and working a lot on on your
leadership and your vision around this
right
is is how do we go and support
organizations that were right now doing
it with direct cash assistance so
i think about the fact that we were able
to work with gib directly
for snap users with low balances work
with cuny to for thousands of low-income
cuny students
you know work with the chinese american
planning council for low-income chinese
immigrants
work with you know with nyc kids rise
for families who are hit the hardest in
communities like queens new york the
most diverse community
in the entire country and so we were
able to do that and use philanthropic
dollars
for those type of things in a way that
we really can prove that things are
working and working to do
working to de-risk it uh i also though
believe to your point
part of the most powerful thing that we
can do is once we can invest in
something
the the things that we've invested in
the most proud of are the things we no
longer invest in
yes yeah right the thing we don't have
to invest in anymore it's either the
problem was solved
or government took it over because the
government now knew that
listen this works one of the proudest
you know one of the things that robin
had often talked about you know kind of
is one of his proudest moments
was we were the first organization that
that invested in needle exchanges
and we did it at a time when it was
really controversial and really scary
and people saying what do you mean
you know giving giving drug dealers
clean needles
well the data was showing that if you're
looking at the rise of hiv aids
it was actually the transmission of
dirty needles that was one of the
fastest
rates for for for this transmission and
so we piloted it
and we funded it and now we don't fund
it anymore no one does because the
federal government does it
but they were never going to be first
money in and so this becomes a unique
opportunity to be able to work with
not just the federal government but
state governments city governments
to be able to say let us test things out
let us be the risk capital
let's do it man where do you want to to
pilot ubi in new york
anywhere robin hood operates was i going
to do this
that's going to be the fruit of the this
conversation
you know my biggest question for u.s is
a personal one
i've known you for years uh and your
biography is remarkable it's the stuff
of
uh frankly like you know almost too good
to be true
made for tv movie type stuff like
jumping out of planes
defending the country trying to fight
poverty at the scale
you're fighting it um i've been in rooms
with you i've been in similar rooms
um and that there were times when i felt
like
and this would be more extreme for you
than would be for me because
you know like and when i was running for
president i actually kind of
realized a little bit of like the role i
was feeling like the persona
um like in your case you're like the
walking inspirational
like hey uh like i'm like the embodiment
of the american dream
um like as a as a leader who's come out
of really difficult
circumstances and and now is someone
that everyone looks to for inspiration
um the personal question is like when i
was in those rooms there were times when
i just felt like screaming my head off
like where like i have that role and
like you know
particularly when i was the head of a
nonprofit because
you were continuously there was like
this
you know dynamic you had where it's like
and now here's inspirational non-profit
leader
and then i'm like okay like i will now
play my role to the best of my ability
um and then you will give me this
um grant maybe if i'm lucky or i did a
good job
and then whatever size the grant is then
like i act like it's the greatest thing
in the world
like even if you know maybe like i was
hoping for something a little different
or bigger
um and and so that there were
times like when i really struggled
personally
now i've known you for years and i've
never really felt from you
like like anything but like 100 like
functional uh sincerity really like you
know like
like you always seem to be inhabiting
yourself and very present um
so i'm just wondering whether or how you
deal with
like any of those uh thoughts or
pressures if you have them or if i'm
just projecting my own
struggles onto you brother uh it is it
is it is an
everyday thing um and but i realized too
it's an everyday thing for all of us
right
and and actually and i i give you i give
you a lot of praise in the fact that you
own it i think there's a lot of people
who walk around like it's not real like
it's not this i mean
um transparency and and
transparency and humility are incredibly
powerful particularly to see in people
that i admire like you because the
reality is that
that pressure is real and and i think
that
part of the thing that i think that kind
of keeps me in a level of center and
and and i know it does for you as well
is
we do walk around knowing that our
narratives
our stories when you consider our
backgrounds and our journeys
are unlikely that we weren't the people
who came from you know this was not a
quote-unquote
societal birthright this was something
that
there were people in our lives
family members friends mentors coaches
etc
who in many ways saw something in us
before we could even see it in ourselves
and i think about in the case of like my
grandfather
where my grandfather was actually the
the first one on my mom's side of the
family born in this country was born in
charleston south carolina
but he wasn't raised here and the reason
was because when he was just a toddler
the ku klux klan ran him and the rest of
my family out of this country
not just out of charleston south
carolina because my gran my great
grandfather was a minister and he's a
very vocal minister
and eventually the verbal threats became
physical ones and he
picked up his family in the middle of
the night and he left this country
and uh and the majority of my family you
know they they vowed to never come back
here
and they didn't my grandfather did
my grandfather was the only one who came
back to the united states
and started his family here with my
great-grandmother was actually from cuba
and they came to the south bronx where
he was a minister the first black
minister in the history of the dutch
former church my grandmother was a
schoolteacher
in the south bronx for almost 30 years
and i think about it in context of this
where
this was a man who
was forced out of this country when he
was just a child some of his earliest
memories
were america's ugliest moments and he
loved this country like no one i knew
and i think about and part of the reason
i have to tell you andrew why i
why when you told me that my first gut
reaction was that you're running my
first
reaction was to hug you because what
else are we supposed to be doing
like this country is an extraordinarily
it's an extraordinarily special
experiment
and it's something that every drop of
progress has been hard earned
it has not been inevitable and it's
something that needed to happen
because the words of this country were
not matching up
to its practices its ideals and its
values
were not matching up to its practices
and so every single bit of progress that
we have made in this country has been
hard-earned and has been hard fought for
and what choice do we have particularly
considering
the past and legacies that we come from
but to fight but to stand up and be
a portion as brave as my grandfather was
as your family was
have a portion of the bravery and the
courage and the loyalty and the
patriotism
that they had and so this i mean this is
this is hard stuff man and sometimes
there is a level this this art
the place that we call home will leave
us with a level of frustration
that is sometimes indescribable
our job isn't to stay there though our
job is to remember
not just why we're here but the progress
we have made and to know that that
progress is going to continue
it's on us we're not responsible for
where things are right now
but the truth is if they're like that 20
years from now that is our cross to bear
that is on us and that's what i just
take seriously
well you certainly embody that through
your action your career
uh the stories that you've been
amplifying
and sharing with the world it's a
privilege to be your friend wes
and it's gonna be a privilege to abolish
poverty alongside you in the days to
come
first in a small part of the country and
then hopefully
society-wide uh so thank you for this
your new book five days it's awesome all
of your books have been spectacular uh
and yeah like all like i'm so glad we
got to sit down i've been looking
forward to this as well uh you know like
i
got lost on the trail for for quite some
time but
but um but like i you know
spending time with you now in this way
it feels a little bit like a homecoming
i feel a little bit like i've gone full
circle
me too brother i'm proud of you man keep
pushing keep prodding we uh
we will be better and we'll do it
together i appreciate you appreciate you
man all the best of the family
you too man thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]